إجابتي أه بيكي هو
أننا كنا في وضع جيد الآن
لدينا مطلقة كاملة وأعني
انهيار مالي كامل ،
انهيار اقتصادي كامل
، قادتنا هذه العلاقة التكافلية
إلى ما نحن فيه والسؤال
هو هذا  آخر مرة ، أعني أنني
أعاني من ليالي بلا نوم أفكر في الأمر ،
لذا بالنسبة لي أعتقد أنه في الحياة
يجب أن تكون هناك مصداقية
وأن ننظر إلى ما نحن فيه الآن 15 عامًا
كنا على وشك نقل لبنان من
بلد إلى وطن وأين  نحن
اليوم
حيث نحن اليوم ، لذلك أنا لا
أتخيل أنا لا أتهم أي شخص ،
أنا فقط أدعو إلى فريق دولي أه
فريق تحقيق يأتي
ويعجل العملية
ويسلط الضوء على هذا لهذا
الحدث المروع
لا يمكننا  نعيش
اليوم في وضع أأ حيث
نحن تحت سيطرة
[الموسيقى] تمامًا
إلى نقطة معينة من
حزب الله
لدينا رئيس يعتقد أن
حزب الله هو
أه ولست شخصًا يسعى إلى
موقف متشدد
ولكن  انا انا  فقط أنا
موقفي اليوم لأن
مكانك لأنه حيث توجد
الأمة أه وأعتقد أن
هناك أه
كما قلت يجب أن تكون هناك
مسؤولية
ونحن في وضع حيث
الجميع يحاول ذلك  أن تكون في أحسن الأحوال
أه
ملتزم بموقف حزب الله